here's the truth living on the road
these past nine months
has been weird the overall vibe is just
really hectic
and basically like kind of the opposite
of why i got into this lifestyle
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
hey guys what's up so uh thank you for
being here
if you are new my name is christian
shafer i'm an outdoor adventure
photographer
and i live in my van full time i've been
living on the road for two and a half
years
and yeah so the last time that we caught
up um
sorry there's a truck going by but the
last time that we caught up i was in
arizona
and i am back in arizona now but between
the last video in this video
a few things have happened i did some
traveling um
and i wanted to update you guys on that
and then also
just kind of like some issues i've been
running into
with living on the road during the
second wave of the pandemic like
i just kind of want to give you guys
more of a
big picture overview like show some
different sides of what it what
this experience has been like because
it's definitely been challenging lately
so yeah um like i said thanks for being
here and i'll just dive right in
so i was in arizona and the weather down
here is perfect
i was camped out in the wilderness and
it was really great
but i had a house sit coming up a pet
sit coming up
that i had scheduled back in um november
and i couldn't exactly cancel it nor
did i want to because i would have left
the the pet owners kind of like high and
dry
so um i had this upcoming pet sit in san
francisco
and things were kind of escalating in
california and it was looking like maybe
things would shut down again
so i was a little bit nervous about
driving all the way out there but like i
said what could i do
so drove out to california and literally
the day
after i did uh california went into
lockdown and they had the
stay-at-home order so that was
unfortunate
um for road life and because the plan
was to stay
was to drive out to san francisco do the
two-week house set
and then stay on california like blm
land travel along the coast and do some
low-key
slow travel um and just still be able to
shower at the campgrounds and the gyms
but with the lockdown all of that was
closed i tried not to think about that
too much
and went ahead with the pet sit which
was amazing
it was in mill valley so it was just
beautiful like the house was amazing and
the two
puppies were so cute oh my gosh there
were two french little bulldogs
and i did the house set with nathaniel
um he's also an outdoor adventure
photographer so it works out really well
for us to do the pet sitting together
because if one of us gets a photo
assignment or we need to go travel
the other person can stay and take care
of the pets so we were there together
and we got out on some adventures we
went um down to the beach which was near
the house we went out to mount tam
and honestly everything was on lockdown
and there was a curfew but
things from the outside i mean they seem
pretty normal still
like we could go to the grocery store we
could go shopping
there was just limited capacity at the
stores we could still
take the dogs out for a walk and go for
a hike as long as we were wearing a mask
and being socially distanced
so yeah it was actually like a really
nice enjoyable time where we could rest
and relax and just kind of like enjoy
being off the road
but when that ended we decided to go up
to point reyes
and hang out there and see how feasible
it was to road life
and oh my gosh it's so beautiful up
there
[Music]
huh
there were some great places to camp and
very easy to social isolate
um but you know by day four i was like
i'd really love a shower
i've been showered since saturday and
it's now thursday so
awesome this is becoming the new norm
with this coronavirus lockdown our only
option
to shower was to go to a truck stop rent
a hotel
or get an airbnb and thought about
just doing truck stops until the
lockdown ended but
the nearest truck stop was like 30
minutes out of the way which seemed
not really very practical we were
talking about it and we thought okay
why don't we just rent an airbnb for a
month
and we can split the cost and that way
we can do it in a cool location
so we can go do like three to four
nights out in the backcountry and we can
take turns even if we want and go do
photo shoots and stuff like that
and just have a place to come back and
shower and have wi-fi and all of that
so that's what we did we booked a
one-month airbnb
and to be honest like it kind of felt
like i was giving up
like i know that sounds stupid but i
almost feel like i'm waving the white
flag when i get a hotel or an airbnb
nate went off and did his own thing and
i did my own thing in socal and then we
met up
and this airbnb that we had booked was
just like
it was a great location it was near
alabama hills death valley and a lot of
other really cool blm locations where we
could go shoot
but the airbnb was just not what we
imagined it would be
like i won't go into too much detail
i'll just say that like
it was super loud it was on an
intersection the walls were really thin
i had a conference call and i had to
lock myself in the bathroom and even
then you could still hear the cars
just roaring by so and there were a few
other things
but like i said i won't go into detail
but
the most important thing is like the guy
who ran the airbnb was so cool he was
great at communication and when we just
told him like hey this probably isn't
going to work for us
we do a lot of audio based work he was
like no problem
he let us cancel and just pay for the
days that we were there which he totally
didn't have to do so
thank you uh that was really nice of him
anyway so we found ourselves back out on
the road
at this point we're like okay we
have a couple options we can either find
another airbnb
um we can cross back into arizona in the
land of
showers or we can maybe go find some blm
land in california
and live off of truck stops and solar
shower
i decided to come back to arizona i'll
admit i have some mixed feelings
about coming back here especially with
everything going on it's a hot spot at
the moment
and there's a lot of unknowns but at the
end of the day
um i don't have a ton of options
aside from like i said renting another
airbnb or buying a house getting a hotel
you can easily social distance out here
even when i went to the gym which i've
been twice now
it's completely empty and i wear a mask
but it's been interesting trying to
navigate you know like weighing
those things like should i go should i
stay because here's the truth
living on the road these past nine
months has been weird
like i won't say that it's been hard
um i know a lot of you out there are
going through way way worse
i'm not trying to complain i just want
to paint a fuller picture for you guys
of
what this has been like because it's
maybe sometimes it looks like it's just
carefree and beautiful and fun and a lot
of times it is
but there's also some downsides so i
just want to share some of those with
you guys to paint a fuller picture
aside from gyms being closed and not
having a solid shower option
except for here in arizona where they're
still open um campgrounds are also
closed
uh or if they're not they're they're
like jam-packed and i get it everyone
wants to get outside
they want to leave their house they want
to go recreate and like only so many
places are open
so naturally they're going to be
overcrowded but a consequence of that is
just that
these places that are usually low-key
and relatively crowd-free
are just overrun with people and trash
is overflowing and in some cases
like there's graffiti and things are
being destroyed
and that's kind of sad to see the
overall vibe is just really hectic
and basically like kind of the opposite
of why i got into this lifestyle one
thing i love about being on the road is
being able to distance yourself from
people like i'm a natural social
distancer i'm also an introvert so
yeah it's hard to do that in these
places that are still open and just like
overrun with crowds
with the campground closures there are a
few other things that are impacting this
lifestyle and that's like having places
to fill the water jugs having places to
dump my toilet and my gray water tank
i usually do that at campgrounds and and
also the showers
and sometimes what that means is i have
to drive way out of my way to go
dump my grey water and toilet which
whatever that's what you have to do to
live this lifestyle
but it does mean unnecessary travel
which is kind of the opposite
of what we'd want to be doing during a
pandemic
it's also just a massive waste of time
gas and money
libraries and coffee shops are closed or
at least indoor seating
is not available and that's kind of been
a big adjustment for me because i know i
have the van to work in
and that's amazing and i love that but
i'm super adhd
and sometimes i literally need to just
walk into the library
and reserve one of those study rooms and
lock myself in there in order to get
real work done like i'm so easily
distracted it's kind of funny
i do get comments fairly often saying
there's no way you actually live in that
fan it's way too clean like someone who
actually lives in that van
it would be a mess and thanks
i guess but like there are a couple
reasons why that is the case
first of all i'm a neat freak but second
of all
i need like very minimal surroundings
very zen surroundings because otherwise
i'm just i'm like a squirrel i'm like
so distracted and it's also an avoidance
tactic
if i'm sitting down to do hard work and
i just don't feel like working
i'll take a look around and be like oh i
could organize that drawer
or i should really clean this wooden
panel even though it doesn't need it
these things on top of the usual
struggles around like getting mail
receiving product shipments for work um
juggling photo assignments and
print sales and emails and keeping track
of expenses for taxes
and just like everything related to
running a business
it's all magnified when you live on the
road because
just like simple tasks like for example
intercepting
a a package for a product i need to
shoot to create content around
which should be simple right just comes
to your house that can turn into like a
full day ordeal of going back and forth
on email
and changing the address and all of
these things
so yeah and then like finding places to
do laundry
places to sleep at night um dealing with
general van maintenance like
oil changes and you know like fixing
things here and there
with the build maintaining that um and
then also maintaining some form of
community and like
staying in touch with family those
things are a little more difficult
for everyone um considering that we're
supposed to keep our distance but
being on the road you already feel a
little bit isolated
and the pandemic has really kind of like
magnified that
so that's just a little update on what
i've been up to
and what it's been like living on the
road lately um
mostly the crappy stuff but i just want
to be honest with
you guys when it comes to that um
the truth though is that like despite
all of these challenges i still love it
out here
like i love sitting by the campfire and
seeing stars at night before i fall
asleep i love
waking up with the sunrise i love the
freedom and the feeling of not being
tethered to any one place
for now i will say that this past year
has taught me that i very much want to
buy land and build my own place and yeah
i'd love to do that in the next year or
two
um at this point i still don't know
which state i want to buy it in and
that's kind of what i'm trying to figure
out by all this
moving around i've only narrowed it down
to the west
west of the rockies but having a place
to call home
and hunker down during times like this
and then also
have the van to go out and travel that's
like my dream
so hopefully in the next year or two
it's my goal to put out more videos
moving forward
so thanks for sticking around head over
to instagram and follow me there
and yeah see you next time
you